these are the worst Power Cuts in 16
years leaving large parts of South
Africa without electricity for 10 hours
or more a day the cause old and badly
maintained infrastructure
poor management and allegations of
corruption at the state-owned energy
utility iscom the daily lives of tens of
millions of South Africans are disrupted
and Facilities such as schools and
hospitals have been severely impacted
trade unions and Civil Society recently
won a court application demanding these
Public Services be exempt from the power
Cuts known as load shedding the safkin
Constitution makes it an explicit task
of the government to provide for health
care provide for safety and to provide
for education
it's clear
that when you don't have energy
you can't deliver on that for the simple
reason that when a child goes to
hospital in an incubator they die
because incubators don't work in the
middle of load sharing operations cannot
be done say crime is increasing during
load shedding because the police simply
don't have the equipment to deal with
crime at the time of load shedding
but the government says the scheduled
outages are preventing a total collapse
of the grid and that exempting certain
areas from the blackouts is impossible
some analysts agree you can't it cut off
a very small individual units the way
this normally works is that entire
suburbs or very large areas get cut off
at the time if you wanted to go to a
much lower level you'd you'd meet far
too many people to do that you need to
go to almost every house and switch them
off so practically it's just not
possible analysts say the only way to
get around this is to supply alternative
energy sources such as diesel generators
or solar panels many public facilities
like this police station have backup
generators to keep the power on but
analysts say the government can't afford
to assist all facilities with
alternative energy sources and certainly
not within two months the installation
would require long-term planning and a
lot of money with the deadline to abide
by the court ruling fast approaching the
government says it plans to appeal the
judgment to keep power Cuts in place
famita Miller Al Jazeera Johannesburg